a new reddit post has just been posted
by mallor's head all he's saying is
bitcoin's about to go parabolic hit 500k
this year and he's putting a hundred
percent of his dip money into the asset
first let's go over why he thinks this
asset is going parabolic this year the
first reason why this reddit user is
bullish on bitcoin is because long-term
holders have continuously trended upward
while short-term holders have trended
downward in the long term first let's
talk about short-term holders if you're
a short-term holder and don't believe in
the asset that's why you're selling
people are buying when the price goes up
as seen in january 2021 of last year and
people are selling when price goes down
because they're fo mowing into the asset
which makes them fearful when the asset
goes down in price if you have long-term
conviction in the asset that means
you're not going to sell when the price
draws down that's why long-term holders
and whales have continuously doubled
down on their conviction in the asset
and have bought more and more bitcoin
regardless of the price speaking of
long-term holders guys like michael
saylor elon musk and many other experts
in the field of bitcoin and other areas
have just held the asset regardless of
pricing they have accumulated more and
more bitcoin throughout the years they
don't care what the price is they're
just holding on to the asset because
they believe in the underlying
technology of the asset and also the
fixed supply of bitcoin using it as a
store of value long-term holders are
actually bullish for the price of
bitcoin because as more people get
adopted to bitcoin and the global
adoption rate increases therefore
because of the fix supply part of it the
price has to go up i completely agree
with this statement now when he says
500k bitcoin price that's where we kind
of divert a little bit i don't really
believe that the bitcoin price can reach
500k this year but it's definitely a
possibility based on historic trends
about how much the asset has appreciated
so rapidly in the coming months and
years after i have it now he also posted
a screenshot of this fear and greed
index i've been seeing on bitcoin
twitter and everywhere listen don't be
fearful or greedy when it comes to
bitcoin just hold the asset when bitcoin
was rising rapidly in the last few
months the greed meter when it was at
forty thousand dollars was at almost an
all-time high and now because the price
has drawn down from all-time highs the
fear meter even though the price is
still the same it says everyone's very
fearful don't worry about it be greedy
when others are fearful and be fearful
when others are greedy this reddit user
put up a fear and greed index on their
post and fear is out of 10 which really
means you can't go lower than a 10 so in
turn we are bullish right now now how do
we get to that 500k price this reddit
user described three floods that are
happening right now but after this he
doesn't believe any funds will ever
happen again the three floods this
reddit usually describes are regulation
the mount gox distribution date and then
russia invading the ukraine so let's
talk about them for regulation
this is really a big deal because as the
crypto industry gets more regulated it
will become more stable and he thinks
that regulation will obliterate both
stable coins and the majority of all
coins all coins regulation is going to
destroy them stable coins i think stable
coins will still be there in the coming
years based off what we've seen mount
gox i don't think anyone cares about
this no one's cared about this for a
very long time so this is irrelevant and
finally russia invading the ukraine he
thinks that if russia invades the
ukraine which hasn't happened but is a
likely possibility based on russia
accumulating a bunch of military
personnel near the border of the ukraine
will actually make energy prices
increase drastically what does that mean
for bitcoin it means that since energy
is getting more expensive mining bitcoin
has become more expensive as well in
turn meaning that miners will have to
mine less or sell their bitcoin to cover
the cost look if anyone sells bitcoin
it's definitely gonna bring down the
price and miners are the ones that are
accumulating bitcoin for verifying
transactions on the blockchain they're
being rewarded bitcoin so they have
bitcoin to sell and they're short-term
holders if they sell their bitcoin it
could bring down the price but nothing
like a whale like michael sayler selling
the reddit user mallor's head brings up
some excellent points in this some of
them are a little egregious i'll call
them but he definitely brings up some
good points and why he's bullish on
bitcoin i personally agree with most of
what he said but not everything now the
main point of this article is because
it's in the headline he thinks that
we're gonna hit 500k bitcoin price i
don't think predictions matter stop
making predictions they don't matter in
the grand scheme of things they're
literally why people do not like
bitcoiners because they're just saying
the price is going to go up to x y z by
this date stop making predictions don't
forget come on this is youtube like
comment and subscribe let's make this go
viral